let's think about what it means to
multiply 2 over 3 or 2/3 times 4/5 times
4/5 in a previous video we've already
seen how we can actually compute this
this is going to be equal to in the
numerator we just multiply the
numerators so it's going to be 2 times 4
2 times 4 and in the denominator or we
just multiply the denominator so it's
going to be 3 times 5 3 times 5 and so
the numerator is going to be 8 and the
denominator is going to be 15 and this
is about as simple as we can make it 8
and 15 don't have any factors common to
each other other than 1 so this is what
it is it's 8:15 so but why does that
actually make sense and to think about
it well we'll think of 2 ways of
visualizing it so let's draw 2/3 so
let's draw 2/3 I'll draw it relatively
big so I'm going to draw 2/3 and I'm
going to take 4/5 of it so 2/3 make it
pretty big 2/3 2/3 just like this so
this is 1/3 and then this would be 2/3
check it a little bit better job making
those equal or at least closer to being
looking equal so there you go I have
thirds let me do it one more time so
here I have drawn thirds 2/3 represents
two of them it represents two of them
and you one way to think about this is
this is 2/3 times 4/5 is 4/5 of this 2/3
so how do we how do we divide this 2/3
into fifths well what if we divided each
of these sections into five so let's do
that so let's divide each into 5 1 2 3 4
5 1 2 3 4 5 and I can even divide this
into 5 if I want one two
two three four five and we want to take
four-fifths of this section here so how
many fifths do we have here we have one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten and we got to be careful these
really aren't fifths these are actually
15s because the hole is this thing over
here so I should really say how many
fifteenth's do we have and that's that's
where we get this number from but you
see you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 where did that come from I had
3 I had thirds and then I took each of
those thirds and I split them into
fifths so then I had five times as many
sections 3 times 5 is 15 but now we want
4/5 of this right over here so we have
this is 1015 s'right over here notice
that's the same thing as 2/3 now if we
want to take 4/5 of that 4/5 of if you
have 10 of something that's going to be
8 of them so we're going to take eight
of them so one two three four five six
seven eight we took eight of the 15 so
that is 815 you could have thought it
the exact about it the other way around
you could have started with fifths so
let me draw it that way so let me draw a
hole so this is a hole and let me draw
it let me cut it into five equal pieces
or as close as I can draw five equal
pieces one two three four five 4/5 we're
going to we're going to shade in four of
them it's four of the five equal pieces
three four and now we want to take 2/3
of that well how can we do that well
let's split each of these five into
three pieces so now we have essentially
15 again so one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten 11 12 13 14 15 and
we want to take 2/3 of this yellow area
we're not taking 2/3 of the whole
section we're taking 2/3 of the four
so how many 15s do we have here we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
so if you have 12 of something and you
want to take 2/3 of that you're going to
be taking 8 of it so you're going to be
taking 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 or 8 of the 15 s
now so either way you get to the same
result you're one way you're thinking of
taking 4/5 of 2/3 another way you could
think of it is you're taking 2/3 of 4/5